what's going on guys this is rob and uh
we're doing a reaction but i didn't feel
like driving all the way to the office
uh to record the reaction for obi-wan
kenobi but i'm really excited so uh
yeah we're gonna do this like the old
school reaction way with like a little
screen down on the bottom so uh yeah
let's let's
let's see how this goes i'm pretty
excited about this i've been looking
forward to the show for a long time so
i'm really excited to see
um what it looks like okay let's let's
let's start this
[Music]
i'm so glad they got you on the road the
fight is done
we lost
[Music]
stay hidden
[Music]
the key
to hunting jedi
is patience
jedi cannot help what they are
their compassion
leaves a trail
the jedi code is like an itch
he cannot help it
where is he
god
[Music]
i don't know who any of these people are
[Music]
was that vader breathing
okay so so not a bad trailer honestly i
was hoping for a little bit more than
what we got um i don't know who anybody
in that trailer is so i'm gonna have to
like read up on all my star wars lore
those are the guys who know who those
people in the trailer are leave comments
down below so i know like who to look
for and who to look up and all that kind
of stuff my knowledge of the star wars
universe is not nearly as comprehensive
as my knowledge on like marvel comics or
the marvel cinematic universe or any of
that kind of stuff so
it's cool it looks really really awesome
no clue what the hell is going on
something like obi-wan kenobi was
looking at luke skywalker and we heard
darth vader's breathing at one point
also
are they like dark sith like like dark
lords of the sith or just like sith
lords or basically just uh sith
themselves because i wasn't aware that
that happened um the last time i was
aware i know that uh
in the star wars mythos god who was it
um but it wasn't freedom freedom nad the
one who developed the rule of two that
before that there were all kinds of wars
and chaos but there were only ever two
uh two sith lords at any given time a
master and an apprentice or was it darth
bane who came up with a rule of two and
that uh before that you had like just a
ton of sith all vying for power and it
was like pandemonium and chaos again my
knowledge is not nearly as comprehensive
this show looks cool but for a person
who's not overly knowledgeable about
star wars it's kind of like
all right
curious to see what it looks like
[Laughter]
but let me know what you guys think down
in the comments section right i know
it's not the most exciting reaction
there ever was i know star wars fans are
just like rob you have no idea how great
it is and i probably don't so explain it
to me right i explain geek culture to
you guys you guys explain star wars to
me
so that i can make videos
and explain it to other people
for watching guys and i'll catch you all
later
peace